m.  Gatsby, j'aimerais savoir exactement
qui tu gagnes ne vois-tu pas qui est
ce gars avec sa maison ses fêtes
des vêtements de fantaisie nous avons été avertis différents
de toi c'est dans notre sang oh rien de ce
que tu fais ou rêve ne peut jamais changer
que
Gatsby, il avait une grande vision de sa
vie depuis qu'il était un garçon, je vais réparer les
choses comme elles étaient
avant toi et moi, aucune quantité de feu ne pourrait
défier le conte de fées qu'il avait
stocké dans son cœur, veux-tu encore  aime-moi
il est tout cela fait entièrement à partir de ta
propre imagination
à propos d'un gars
comme
ma vie ma vie doit être comme ça
elle doit continuer